σκέφτηκε σθα αυταμσε αυτό το επίπεδο δεν ήξερα κάνετι να το αλμε εσύψως ότε επίστεψα
ότι απλά δεν θέλω να έχουν μια εφάνηση θέλο να έχο μια διάκριση το κράτος
είναι δίπλα στους αθλητές να υπάρχουν κίνητα να μην ναντικίνητράμασαν επρωπακή χώρα ιστερούμε πολύ σεστο
κεφάλιο υποδόμέ σεωρώ ότι τερούμε πάρα θεωρίσω ότι έκλεησης στην καριάασ όπως ή θέλες όχι
πολύ θέλα να δείξουν α οπούν πρόσωπο οιμονο εξεχάσαμε κλείσαν οι πόρτες ενμου να ποδεκτώς
δεν μου την ετάλλον περιθόρεο παράνα κίνηθούμε με την νομικίνο οδώ πραγματικά όταν όταν εκανά
την πρώτη μου νορημία με το αρμα εσύψωση είναι αυτό τ έρωτας που με την
πρώτη μου ματιά πουλέ διποναφανταστώ των εαυτό μου με κάτι διαφορετικούλετακάλλον αντλλά επορκα σήμερα μαζί
σας αφήνουμε για λίγο τις πολιτικές της στην άκρυ και μαζί μας ένας προεινολυμπιονίκης να
σαφλητής πουγραψει τη δική του ιστορία στο άλμα εσύψως και μαζί μας ο κυριάκο ιοα
κυριά χως ευχαριστώ πολύ που είσα σήμερ μαζί μου θσεαμεεγώ ευχαριστώ έν τηςιδιαίτερη χαρά που
αποδέκτηκα την προσκληση του α σε ευχαριστώ παραπολύ θε να γάνω ότην παραδοσια καίρωση που
κάνωσε όλους καλεσμένους ποιο εσ ποιος συνοκύρι ποιώκυρικοσιώνω ήταν ας προεναθλήτης έφθασαν στο εψηλότερο εν
επίπεδο του κλασικού αθλητισμού έχω αγώνειστη σε όλες τις μεγάλες διοργανώσεις και σχεδόν έχω διακριθεή
σε όλες δηλαδή από παγκόσμε π δαθλήματα κακληστού ανοικτου στίβου ευρωπαικά τέστερις ολιμπιακούς αγώνες έλαβα
μέρος με την καλύτερι μου εφάνηση το ρίο το ότιχλιτης εκάέξι σ ανέβδομοσολημπιονίκης που στην
ουσία ήταν και η τηλευταία μου στοπούμε επιθημία και